welcome to Hannity tonight so much
breaking news we will be covering
throughout the entire hour tonight
now both officers are charged in the
race hard Brooks killing that's the one
in Atlanta they have now also
surrendered and we have key details new
details surrounding the arrest that you
didn't hear from the district attorney
yesterday keep in mind you can indict a
ham sandwich but the high bar will be 12
people on a jury beyond a reasonable
doubt there's a lot of developments but
first tonight I want us all to step back
as a country we need to step back take a
collective deep breath and understand
this moment and realize this country is
at a tipping point it's dangerous
we're at a point where we will either go
the way of law and order peace
prosperity one American family and the
way of safety in the way of security or
we will go down the road of liberal
lawlessness and total anarchy now
because the sweeping broad in many cases
false generalizations of groups of
people and let's be honest outright lies
at times well that we are about seeing
officers police officers and the smears
against those that stand in the way of
chaos and you will in the safety of your
family this non-stop rush to judgment is
intensifying all around the country
especially in big cities by the hour
now this madness to defund dismantle
destroy police departments it is now a
clear and present danger to the entire
country people will and we'll have more
details later as dan Henninger pointed
out in The Wall Street Journal
they will be fleeing big cities and
droves police across the country now are
under attack it is unfair it is sick and
it is twisted not all cops are bad 99
percent as a matter of fact our heroes
look at the city of Atlanta where just
last night it appears that we are now
seeing the beginning it actually has a
name a lot of police are calling in sick
the name blue flu large numbers of
officers are calling in sick basically
saying you know what enough is enough
following the charges in the Brooks case
the officers they have lost faith in
their leadership they have lost faith in
their ability to actually be able to
perform their jobs to the best of their
ability this even acknowledged by the
Atlanta mayor Keisha Lance bottoms hey
Democrat even she is admitting morale is
down tenfold here's a question do you
blame them take a look across the
country morale is down with Police
Department and I think ours is down
tenfold this has been a very tough few
weeks in Atlanta and according to a new
report from the New York Post tonight
NYPD officers new york city they are
being encouraged to strike on the 4th of
July although a department spokesman is
denying that well that strike will occur
really can you guarantee that because if
that happens not just in New York City
but in cities across the country I
promise you that will not end well for
We the People it's now becoming
untenable for the good police officers
to do their jobs and do it safely with
the support of the community and those
politicians it's disgraceful it's unfair
it's unjust and it's happening they rush
to judgment broad sweeping
generalizations they're all racist as we
have been reporting by the way so many
major cities that we talk about happen
to have a majority of minorities on the
job in other words a majority of
minority police officers and while I
don't necessarily endorse the idea of
the blue flu because of what could
potentially happen we have to ask
ourselves put yourself in their shoes
how would you be feeling today in other
words would you like being called the
racist or thought of as a racist or as
we've seen in New York have buckets of
water poured on your car and it be
assaulted and not have a mayor that
supports you and then have you know
politicians we have oh the forgetful Joe
and Konrad de Blasio oh this is all
racism well how do you think those
officers that aren't racist that put
their lives on the line for us every
single day at night how do you think
they feel given the circumstances now
given the fact that liberal cities like
we've been talking about New York
Seattle
Chicago Detroit or surrendering too far
left lawlessness and anarchy and making
it harder and harder if not impossible
now for police officers to do their jobs
earlier today the new york police union
chief Pat Lynch told Fox News quote you
are seeing these messages from New York
City police officers because they now
have reached the breaking point pay
close attention they're communicating
something very loudly to We the People
over the past few weeks we have been
attacked in the streets demonized in the
media denigrated by practically every
politicians in the city and state now
some police officers as a result of the
violent rioters not the peaceful
protesters there are peaceful people but
some of them are not a lot of them are
not someone now police officers are dead
800 plus injured rocks bricks Molotov
cocktails what we are seeing play out
across the country with these officers
being attacked run over shot targeted is
unacceptable they will begin to leave
this profession in droves and frankly
ask yourself can you really blame them
800 officers injured rocks bricks
bottles Molotov cocktails others have
died and some are paralyzed from the
neck down it should disturb every good
decent American that believes in law and
order ask yourself again what do you
think your community wherever you happen
to be tonight will look like if these
far-left leaders get their way what's
going to happen when these police
officers say we're retiring thanks but
no thanks
again I ask the question who are you
going to call when it's 10 11 12 o'clock
at night and somebody's breaking into
your house to do harm to you and your
family and your children what are you
going to do heaven forbid when violence
strikes
we're at a point now where police
they're going to go on strike they're
going to quit they're going and they're
being blamed for the bad actions we all
acknowledge this it was universal
agreement in the case of George Floyd
and at our country we always want to be
a more perfect union we can we will get
better the president laid out reforms to
make us better
Howard Department
going to recruit good new candidates
don't usually pay a whole lot of money
either especially in the early years of
being a police officer how our Police
Department's supposed to function in an
environment like this now I want to be
very clear
of course accountability is good of
course we need to expose abuse of power
corruption at all levels we do it on
this show every night we did it at the
highest levels of the deep state within
the FBI of all places within our
intelligence community of all places but
we always said the one percent not the
good 99% what is going on right now with
the Steve fund Police movements and no
more police movements picking up steam
well that will obviously you don't need
a Harvard degree this will lead to a
crime wave this will lead to an exodus
from cities like you have never seen I
go back to this piece Wall Street
Journal Dan Henninger explaining that
liberal lawlessness and failed far-left
governance is simply making life too
stressful too chaotic and crime-ridden
to still live in places like New York
and San Francisco and Minneapolis and
many other big cities what will these
cities do when their tax base like
Chicago for example they move to states
that don't have income taxes let's see
Florida Texas Arizona or states like the
Carolinas Tennessee lowered no taxes at
all whatsoever look at your screen
states like California New York well
they have a mass exodus going on already
they've been losing residents long
before all of this and just look at the
u-haul cost let's say you want to move
from California to Texas okay guess what
if you're moving from Texas to
California you're going to pay a lot
less as a matter of fact it's about
$2,500 to move from California to Texas
but only about 400 bucks to go back oh
you're doing u-haul a favor because they
need those trucks because people are
racing out of California and by the way
these men and women that put their lives
on the line every day for you and your
families well they they do this because
they love what they do they're willing
to take on the wrists and all day and
every night they mostly
99% do an amazing job they save lives
they keep us safe and yet liberal
leaders are trying to turn them into
villains and then they are the exact
opposite